[Music]
this is what I'm talking about what we
say this is the level that we expect on
the red carpet I agree I appreciate you
they do full out right now so tell me
about your look how did you pick I
wanted to you know I went to my stylist
and I was like I wanna kind of look like
an intergalactic space would ya and this
is what he came up with so I was like I
was really happy I'm here to prove up my
son walk if I knew ABS oh I love this
okay so this is reminiscent of a Madonna
[ __ ] and a Madonna performed like a
virgin at the first VMAs and the first
VMAs were at Radio City Music Hall so
look at this ground moment for Heidi
Blair yes move it Jennifer Lopez is
getting the video Vanguard Award tonight
is there a Jennifer Lopez video that
means the world to you were inspired you
or that you've loved that you may be
dressed up for and Halloween time Wow
she killed that I mean that's kind of
what really pops are often made her like
she's like a triple threat or you do
everything she's amazing
what do you think since you do give a
lot of love advice out there in the
world what do you think of Jennifer
Lopez and a-rod you like them together I
think they're beautiful
I think love is beautiful oh so it
doesn't you know if you find love that's
a beautiful thing
[Music]
[Applause]